it's still winter but soon enough
amusement parks will be filled with
spring breakers and then summer vacation
thrill seekers i recently chatted with
folks at busch gardens about their brand
new ride called iron gwazi
are you a roller coaster fanatic well
even if you're not wait till you see the
newest craziest coaster coming to busch
gardens in tampa bay next month it's
called the iron gwazi and here to give
us a sneak peek is andy schafer director
of design and engineering at busch
gardens and jonathan smith vp of
engineering at sea world
partners in this crazy
wonderful new roller coaster all right
guys welcome it's so nice to talk to you
you're sitting in the coaster itself
first of all i've got to ask where's the
name come from iron gwazi
so it is a crocodile themed roller
coaster so it's crocodile inspired
thrills and it's an extremely thrilling
coaster it is north america's tallest
and it is the world's fastest and
steepest hybrid coaster it's an
incredible ride experience once in a
generation record-breaking attraction
and with us today is 24 of our friends
from the american coaster enthusiast
joining us say hi guys
[Applause]
and we're going to give you a quick
preview of what iron guazi is all about
here busch gardens tampa bay so if
you're okay you can join us for the ride
we just left the station and we're
making our way to the lift hill which is
a 45 degree ascent
where we're going to hit height of 206
feet
so we're going to get a great view of
the
stamp on landscape in the city of tampa
behind us no no this is the part i don't
like guys four thousand feet
we get such a great view right here
and uh we are making our way down
we're gonna hit about 91 degrees here
it'll be a little inverted
is designed like an old-fashioned
coaster but uses a steel track for a
super smooth ride zooming at speeds of
76 miles per hour riders get a dozen
airtime moments including three
inversions while you're racing along 4
000 feet of track and because the
minimum height requirement to ride it is
48 inches that means even younger kids
can go for the thrill too
right here
so that's iron
at busch gardens tampa we are having
past member previews starting this
weekend and it opens to the general
public on march 11th
oh
okay oh my goodness so we will be open
in time for spring break and then of
course for summer if you have a year
round pass to busch gardens you could be
riding it right now so go for it
uh yeah my stomach is still back there
on the track somewhere you were talking
to him while he was riding the roller
coaster yes he talked to me the whole
time i took every twist and turn with
them
it was unbelievable especially that
first drop i was like no i don't no no
no no i don't need to see that
a 91 degree almost inversion
it's not straight down it's a little
inverted as you go down
it's so maybe don't don't have lunch
before you go on that i wouldn't i'm
thinking no corn dogs that day all right
okay no corn dogs nothing or at least
maybe a little while after yeah if you
can handle it
something's over there it's deep is
tallest fastest put your legs back under
you it's a very cool terry
it really did